Bitte schön.
Okay. Können wir starten?
Hallo.
Hallo. Grüß Sie.
Ja. Kann ich Vorstellung?
Kann ich mich vorstellen?
Nein, Vorstellung.
Heute bitte grammatikalisch einwandfrei.
Wie bitte?
Ohne Fehler.
Okay.
So.
Hallo. Grüß Sie.
Ich freue mich so sein.
Bevor wir mit der Prüfung anfangen,
hatte ich mich gerne kurz vorstellen.
Möchte ich mich gerne kurz vorstellen?
Ja.
Möchte ich mich kurz vorstellen?
Mhm.
So, ich habe mein Medizinstudium und die Facharzt-Weiterbildung
in der Türkei abgeschlossen.
Und arbeite schon seit 15 Jahren
als Internets in der Türkei.
Und im Jahr 2022 habe ich
drei Monate in Heidelberg
eine Sprachschule besucht.
Dann
letztes Jahr absolvierte ich
eine Hospitation in einer Praxis in Konstanz
und die Onkologieabteilung
der Universität Klinik
in Halle.
In den letzten sechs Monaten habe ich
eine private Unterricht,
der von Berlin
aus Stadt finden genommen.
Sie meinen privaten Deutschunterricht?
Ja.
Und dadurch habe ich mich
nicht nur auf die Prüfung vorbereitet,
sondern auch meine Kommunikationsfähigkeit
verbessert.
Okay.
Nach der Zeit,
die ich Deutschland verbracht habe,
fühle ich mich bereits besser
in der deutschen Kultur
und quasi Gesundheitssystem integriert.
Nach der Untersuchung würde ich
in der Onkologieabteilung arbeiten
oder müsste ich
noch einmal
versuchen, die Prüfung zu bestehen.
Vielen Dank.
Ja, okay.
Was ich nicht verstanden habe,
ist die Untersuchung.
Nach Abschluss der Prüfung meinen Sie?
Ja, nach Abschluss der Prüfung
möchte ich gerne in der Onkologie arbeiten.
Sehr gut.
Eine Sache wichtig
von der Formulierung her,
Sie haben gesagt,
ich arbeite seit 15 Jahren als Internist.
Sie konnten ja nicht durchgehend arbeiten.
Das heißt, es gab ja die Unterbrechung,
als sie aus der Türkei geflüchtet sind.
Also müssten Sie sagen,
seit meiner Approbation bis zum Jahr X,
habe ich in der Türkei als Internist gearbeitet
und dann kommen Ihre Arbeitsschritte
hier in Deutschland.
Gut. Aber sonst haben Sie sehr schön das Vorbereit.
Gut, jetzt fangen wir
unser Simulation an.
Schönen guten Tag.
Ich bin Issa Altham.
Ich bin der Diensthaber in dieser Praxis.
Ich möchte heute mit Ihnen
dieses Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Ist das in Ordnung so für Sie?
Ja.
Bevor Sie mir Ihre Beschwerden erzählen,
möchte ich ganz schnell ein paar Fragen
Ihnen stellen.
Ich meine Besuch auf Ihr Alter, Ihr Groß, Ihr Gewicht.
Sind Sie damit...
Ich möchte Sie eine Person nicht da.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Mein Name ist Issa Altham.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Namen langsam büchtern?
Ja, das sind ganz kurze Wörter.
EVA, EVA ist der Vorname.
Ja.
Und Hase, H, A, S, E, wie das Tier mit den langen Ohren.
Entschuldigung.
Könnten Sie bitte...
Hase.
Nein, nur eines.
Okay.
Präuhase.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Geburtstatung verraten?
Ich bin jetzt noch 49.
Ich werde dieses Jahr 50.
50, okay.
Und wie groß, wie schwer sind Sie?
Was möchten Sie wissen, wie groß oder wie schwer?
Ja, wie groß und schwer.
Also ich bin jetzt 49.
Ich bin jetzt 49.
Ich bin jetzt 75.
Ich bin jetzt 75 groß.
Und ich wiege 80 Kilo.
80 Kilo.
Okay, Frau Hase.
Was führt Sie so um mich?
Ich habe solche heftigen Rhythmenschmerzen.
Ich war gestern im Garten.
Ich habe die erste Schredder.
Dann habe ich das schwere Gerät aus dem Schuppen geholt.
Da ist es mir reingefahren in den Rücken.
Und jetzt habe ich solche Rhythmenschmerzen,
dass ich mich kaum bewegen kann.
Das schießt bis in den rechten Oberschenkel rein.
Und so an der Seite zieht es runter.
Und also,
ich weiß kaum noch, wie ich mich bewegen soll.
Ich habe das Gerät nicht wieder zurückbekommen.
Das musste mein Mann zurück tragen in den Schuppen.
Ich habe das nicht mehr hochheben können.
Die Schmerzen sind wirklich sehr unangenehm.
Ich habe heute Nacht fast nicht geschlafen.
Ich kann mich überhaupt nicht bewegen.
Okay.
Zerätung, die Schmerzen nach Gartenarbeiten aufrichtet?
Ja, ich habe das Gerät nicht wieder zurückbekommen.
Ich habe das Gerät gerade geschildert.
Ich habe ein schweres Gerät hochgehoben.
Dabei ist es mir in den Rücken reingeschossen.
Okay, okay.
Das kann ich verstehen.
Hatten Sie schon einmal eine Besperre erleden?
Oder ist das zu märzen?
Ja, also, wenn ich lange im Garten arbeite,
dann habe ich das Gerät nicht mehr.
Ja, also, wenn ich lange im Garten gearbeitet habe,
in gebückter Haltung und Unkraut rausgehakt habe,
oder so etwas, ja, wenn ich dann hochgekommen bin,
dann hat es schon mal weh getan.
Aber jetzt, so wie heute, dass ich also kaum noch
mich bewegen kann, das habe ich überhaupt noch nie gehabt.
Nein.
Okay.
Das Schmerzen ist heute sehr schrecklich.
So, haben Sie für das Schmerz,
seit wann leiden Sie leichte Schmerzen?
Ach ja, das habe ich immer mal wieder,
wenn ich im Garten arbeite, also immer im Sommer,
seit Jahren, das ist ja nichts Neues,
dass einem einmal der Rücken wehtut,
wenn man immer krumm arbeitet.
Aber jetzt, dass ich solche Schmerzen habe,
wie gesagt, das ist jetzt akut.
Okay, okay.
Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen strahlen
rechte Oberschenkel aus, richtig?
Genau.
Und Sie haben Bewegung, Einschränkung.
Mit wem sind Sie ins Krakenhaus gekommen?
Mein Mann hat mich mit dem Auto gebracht, ja.
Aber ich, weil kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen,
wie ich in das Auto rein und wieder rausgekommen bin.
Ja, das war sehr schwierig.
Okay, okay, das ist bestimmt sehr schwer für Sie.
So, Frau Hase,
könnten Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben,
ist er dumpf zunehmend, möchte er nicht einschließen?
Nein, der Schmerz brennt, ja.
Und tatsächlich kribbelt das praktisch am ganzen Bein herunter außen,
bis in den kleinen Zee rein.
Kribbelt.
So, beide Seite oder nur rechte Oberschenkel?
Nein, rechts, rechts an der Außenseite.
Okay.
Und haben Sie auch Taubheit gefühlt?
Ja, dieses Kribbeln, das ist ja so was wie ähnliches,
wie ein Taubheitsgefühl, ja.
Das ist, ja, so ein bisschen.
Könnten Sie bitte genau mir
der Tropfenbereich an der Kribbel
beschreiben, nur unter...
An der Außenseite des rechten Beines.
Außenseite.
Außenseite des rechten Beines.
Und so, die Stark sind die Schmerzen.
Oh, sehr stark, sehr stark.
Der Stark, der Stark.
Von eins bis zehn, ein sehr leichte Schmerz,
und sie sind sehr stark, die Schmerzen.
Wo würden sie einordnen, sie?
Also bei acht sind die ganz bestimmt, ja.
Haben Sie etwas gegen eingenommen?
Eine Schmerzmittel, oder?
Nein, ich habe jetzt noch nichts eingenommen,
weil ich gehofft habe, es würde auch so wieder weggehen,
aber es sind schon wirklich sehr starke Schmerzen.
Ich habe heute Nacht also wirklich so gut wie nicht geschlafen.
Okay.
Wenn Sie möchten, gebe ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel.
Möchten Sie?
Ein Schmerzmittel, ja, das wäre vielleicht ganz gut,
damit ich das besser aushalten kann, ja.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie eine Allergie gegen Schmerzmittel oder nicht?
Gegen Schmerzmittel eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe nur gegen Penicillin, gegen eine bestimmte Sorte,
habe ich eine Allergie,
aber bei Schmerzmitteln ist eigentlich nichts bekannt.
Okay.
Sie geben die Schmerzmittel sofort.
Und gibt das bestimmte Auslöserpapier für die Schmerzen,
zum Beispiel beim Husten oder was würden Sie sagen?
Ich habe Ihnen doch jetzt ausführlich ein Auslöser beschrieben.
Die Schmerzen wurden ausgelöst durch schweres Heben.
Schweres Heben.
Ein Auslöser.
Schweres Heben im Rahmen von Gartendarbeit.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ja, und seitdem bestehen diese Schmerzen und werden nicht besser.
Okay, okay.
So, haben Sie auch Fieber oder Schuteltbrot?
Nein, ich kann mich nicht rühren,
aber Fieber habe ich nicht.
Nein.
Und so, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Naja, also heute schmeckt es mir jetzt nicht so gut,
weil ich mich überhaupt nicht bewegen kann,
weil ich mich schlecht fühle,
aber normalerweise kann ich gut essen, ja.
Ich muss allerdings aufpassen, weil ich Diabetes habe,
aber das kenne ich schon.
Aber mein Appetit ist in Ordnung.
Okay, okay.
So, haben Sie Schlafstörung außer gestern Schmerzbedingungen?
Normal kann ich gut schlafen.
Gut schlafen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Strugang?
Naja, beim Strugang das einzige, was ich da weiß,
ist, wenn ich Rohlebensmittel esse,
also Rohes Gemüse, Rohesobst,
dann kriege ich manchmal Blähungen,
aber sonst habe ich keine Probleme mit dem Verdauen.
Okay, okay.
So, Frau Haase, Sie haben gesagt,
Sie leiden an,
die Abendschmerz, die Sucherkrankheit.
Seit wann haben Sie?
Ich bin schon.
Das ist also ein Typ eines Diabetes, ja.
Und ich habe eine Insulinkumpel,
und damit komme ich gut zu euch.
Okay.
Und gibt es noch andere Vorherkruckungen?
Ja, also ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck,
das hat man vor sieben Jahren mal festgestellt.
Und außerdem sind auch die Blutfettwerte ein bisschen hoch.
Okay.
Und das war alles, oder gibt es noch was?
Ja, eine Sache,
das vielleicht weiß ich nicht, ob das wichtig ist,
ich hatte vor anderthalb Jahren mal ein Hörsturz,
und da ist mir so ein leichter Tinnitus geblieben.
Tinnitus. Okay.
Haben Sie gegen Blutdruck eine Medikamente eingenommen?
Ich nehme regelmäßig meine Tabletten, ja, natürlich, ja.
Ich bekomme also einmal Insulin, dann nehme ich Mikardis,
und dann noch Atorastatin und Thebonin.
Thebonin.
Mikardis, wie viel Milligramm ist das?
Das heißt Mikardis plus 40 zu 12,5 steht da drauf.
Ein Entschuldigung.
Mikardis plus 40 zu 12,5.
Und dann nehme ich morgens und abends eine.
Und Atorastatin?
Das nehme ich abends.
Abends. Wie viel Milligramm?
Ich meine das in 10 Milligramm.
Und Thebonin?
Das sind 120 Milligramm, meine ich, und das nehme ich abends.
Okay.
Herr Frau Kaze, würden Sie schon einmal operiert, oder?
Ne, eine Operation habe ich tatsächlich noch nie gehabt.
Würden Sie schon einmal ins Krankenhaus eingeliefert?
Ja, als ich meine Kinder bekommen habe, da bin ich im Krankenhaus gewesen.
Ja, aber sonst eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Ach so, na ja, natürlich, bei dem Hörsturz war ich auch kurzfristig in der Klinik,
bin aber dann schnell wieder entlassen worden.
Und Sie haben gesagt, gegen die Allergie, Pensilienallergie.
Ja, das ist Amoxicilin.
Amoxicilin.
Wann wurde das geschworen?
Das ist so 2 Jahre.
Vor 2 Jahren.
Okay.
Müssen Sie eine Amoxicilin einnehmen?
Warum nehmen Sie Amoxicilin?
Ja, da hatte ich irgendeinen komischen Infekt.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was das war.
Und jedenfalls habe ich da also Joghreit bekommen,
und dann hat man das weggelassen.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Allergie, oder?
Ja, also im Frühling, wenn die Haselnussblüte ist,
dann habe ich Schwierigkeiten.
Also Haselnusspollen, das macht bei mir Augen, Jucken,
und Tränen, und so Schnupfenreaktionen.
Okay.
Sie haben gegen Rohreleimansmittel unverträglich.
Die kann ich nicht gut vertragen.
Also Rohre Sachen kann ich nicht gut vertragen.
Da kriege ich halt Mott, Bauchschmerzen und Leone.
Leone.
Okay.
Ja, wissen wir, lassen uns über ihre Gewohnheiten schiessen.
Frau Hase, rauchen Sie?
Das kann man nicht wirklich Rauchen nennen.
Also ich habe mir das so angewöhnt,
dass ich so zwei, dreizeigaretten nach am Tag rauche.
Nach dem Mittagessen und dann am Abend noch mal eine,
und dann vielleicht noch mal eine am Nachmittag,
wenn man mit den Kollegen noch mal zusammensitzt.
Aber ich rauche nicht wirklich,
weil er rausgekriegt.
Okay.
Seit wann rauchen Sie drei oder vier?
Eigentlich erst, seit die Kinder auf der Welt sind,
als sie ein bisschen größer waren, also ungefähr 15 Jahre.
15 Jahre.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke abends gerne Glas Wein.
Ja, wenn wir zusammensitzen, Feierabend, ja, dann trinken wir gerne Glas Wein.
Glas Wein.
Abends oder?
Ja, zum Abend.
Abends.
Ja, Frau Hase, bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht per se.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie eine Droge?
Drogen?
Das ist schon lange her, da habe ich mal ein bisschen Gras geraucht.
Habt es mal probiert, aber das war nicht so doll.
Also habe ich dann wieder sein gelassen, ja.
Haben Sie einmal probiert?
Ja, so ein paar Mal, aber nie ein regelnissiger Konsument.
Okay.
Also, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Bauingenieurin.
Bauingenieurin.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ich habe Ihnen ja gesagt, man hat mir geholfen und hat mich hier in die Klinik gebracht.
Ja, ja, ja, ich weiß.
Haben Sie auch Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Sohne.
Zwei Sohne.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder sind gesund, ja.
Gut.
Und Sie wohnen mit zusammen?
Wir wohnen alle zusammen, ja.
Okay.
Okay, und Ihr Alter, Frau Hase, lebt Ihr Alter noch?
Meine Eltern leben noch, ja, ja, zum Glück.
Sind Sie gesund, Frau Hase?
Ja, meine Mutter hat Probleme mit den Augen.
Die hat so eine Makulaproblematik.
Und musste also regelmäßig Tropfen nehmen und so.
Und ja, hat eben ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten.
Und bei meinem Vater ist es eine Hüftersatz geplant,
weil er Probleme mit der einen Hüfte hat.
So, Rettel oder beides Seite?
Im Augenblick ist, glaube ich, links das Schlimmerere und da ist jetzt die OP geplant.
Okay.
Sind Sie ein sehr Kind oder haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin ein sehr Kind, ja, ja, haben wir Geschwister.
Okay.
Frau Hase, ich bin mit meinem Pfleidung praktisch.
Möchten Sie etwas Hünse fügen oder haben Sie eine Frage?
Ja, also ich will natürlich wissen, was man gegen die Schmerzen machen kann.
Und wenn die dann weg sind, wüsste ich natürlich gerne,
wie ich das verhindern kann, dass das jemals wiederkommt.
Denn ich kann dich jetzt ja nicht in Wasch packen.
Also ich muss ja weiterarbeiten, ja.
Also woher kommt es und was kann man dagegen tun?
Das ist die Frage, ne?
Ja, ja.
Frau Hase, ich möchte gerne Ihnen erklären.
So, ich kann nachvollsehen,
dass Sie die Ursache Ihrer Beschwerde möglichst schnell wissen möchten.
Unser Geschenke-Seit ist vorbei.
Ja, gut, jetzt machen Sie noch eben schnell die Erklärung.
Um jedoch genaue Diagnose zu stellen,
sind verschiedene Untersuchungen,
wie Körteli-Untersuchungen,
und Brut-Untersuchungen, Bilgeber-Untersuchungen erforderlich.
Und derzeit besteht der Verdacht
auf eine Bandscheibe-Vorfall.
Aber so Bestätigung sind verschiedene weitere Untersuchungen
notwendig.
Was ist damit zufrieden?
Ja, ja, okay.
Gut, dann möchte ich gleich was zu sagen.
Legen Sie sich doch nicht zu dieser frühen Zeit
mit der Diagnose fest der Patientin gegenüber.
Bleiben Sie dabei?
Wir haben jetzt ein paar Informationen von Ihnen gesammelt.
Jetzt müssen wir ein paar Untersuchungen machen.
Wenn die Untersuchungen abgeschlossen sind,
kann ich Ihnen genau sagen, was Ursache ist
und was wir dagegen tun können.
Nicht im Vorfeld eine Diagnose stellen.
Okay, okay.
Wobei ich schon sagen würde,
wenn das so eindeutig ist, wie die Verdachtdiagnose ist,
dass diese Patientin weder ein Magen-Darm-Problem
noch irgendwas mit dem Herzen hat,
liegt so relativ auf der Hand.
Da würde man vielleicht diese Fragen
nach Luftnot oder was, was ich Wasser lassen,
vielleicht vernachlässigen können.
Denke ich.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Meine Seite.
Ja, ich habe eine.
Bitte schön.
Okay, Frau Hase,
könnt ihr die Schmerzen genau lokalisieren?
Also wo befinden Sie sich die Schmerzen?
Oh, also im unteren Rücken,
mit Rechtsorientierung.
Also der Rechte ist, schießt in den rechten Oberschenkel rein.
Okay, sie meinen Ländenschmerzen.
Ja, so kann man sagen.
Okay.
Ja, vielleicht so.
Dann, zweite,
haben Sie Lähmungerscheinungen
in Ihrem rechten Bein?
Lähmungerscheinungen nicht.
Ich habe so ein bisschen Taubheitsgefühl, ja.
Aber keine Kraftverlust, ne?
Keine Kraftlosigkeit, nein.
Okay, danke schön.
Also Frau Hase,
haben Sie etwas dagegen tun?
Zum Beispiel haben Sie Heiß oder Kalt abbeziert
oder Medikamente eingenommen?
Nee, Medikamente habe ich nicht eingenommen.
Das hat Ihr Kollege auch gefragt.
Aber ich habe mich auch, also ich habe weder warm noch kalt,
irgendwie, oder weder wärme noch kälte, abbeziert.
Ich war also kaum in der Lage, mich überhaupt zu bewegen, ja.
Ich war froh, als ich in meinem Bett lag
und mich nicht mehr rühren musste.
Hatten Sie früher zum Arzt für diese Beschwerden gegangen?
Nee, ich bin damals nicht zum Arzt gegangen,
als ich diese kleinen Beschwerden hatte,
weil sich das dann irgendwann wieder gegeben hat, ja.
Ja.
Das war nie von langer Dauer, dass mir der Rücken wehgetan hat.
Das war nie so, dass ich mich veranlasst gesehen habe, zum Arzt zu gehen.
Okay, verstanden, danke.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Leiden Sie unter muskelsche Weine in Ihre Beine, rechte Beine?
Muskelschwächen? Nicht, nein.
Okay. Leiden Sie unter Sensibilitätstörungen?
Möglicherweise. Also ich habe gesagt, es kribbelt
und es fühlt sich ein bisschen taub an.
Ich müsste mal jetzt austesten, ob es da wirklich Sensibilitätstörungen
gehört, ne?
Okay, danke schön.
Ein Thema für die körperliche Untersuchung.
Leiden Sie Sport? Regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, also ich mache regelmäßig Gartenarbeit.
Ich fahre auch regelmäßig mit dem Fahrrad,
aber dass ich jetzt irgendwie so gerätetraining oder so was mache,
das mache ich nicht, nein.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Gerne.
Frau Hase, seit wann haben Sie Rückenschmerzen?
Ich habe nicht gehört, ob diese Frage gestellt hat oder nicht.
Also diese Schmerzen, jetzt habe ich seit gestern.
Seit gestern.
Ja, und ich bin dann praktisch sofort gekommen,
als die Nacht so schlecht war und keine Verbesserung gebracht hat.
Okay, danke schön.
Die Gehnekologie ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Die Einstattung ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Ja.
Und die Frage ist, ob es die Schmerzen gibt,
aber ob es die Schmerzen gibt,
ob es die Schmerzen gibt,
weil es eine differenzielle Diagnose gibt.
Ich habe zum Beispiel Diagnose, zum Beispiel, denken.
Aber müssen wir stellen diese Frage.
Die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen sie auch wieder durch.
Aber ich meine, hätte er gefragt,
ob die Schmerzen dauerhaft sind.
Nein, nicht so.
Ich habe mich da festgelegt,
dass die Schmerzen nicht weggegangen sind.
Ja, ich meine, er hat gefragt,
ob er das besser gemacht hat oder so.
Und ich habe gesagt, nee,
es war die ganze Zeit, wo ich war.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestattet.
Können wir Arsatzgespiele anfangen?
Bitte, ja.
Bitte schön, jetzt.
Guten Tag Frau Arsatz.
Ich würde gerne eine Patientin mit Ihnen besprechen,
die ich gerade in die Zentralnotaufnahme aufgenommen habe.
Darf ich die Patientin vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Vielen Dank Frau Oberarstin.
Es geht um Frau Hase,
die 50 Jahre alt, 1,75 Meter groß und 80 Kilogramm schwer.
Die Patientin befand sich,
seit Punktes gesprochen,
die Schmerzbedingte Residuärtem alle Gemeinsuchstand
und war vollständig orientiert.
Orientiert?
Orientiert.
Ja, Frau Hase stellte sich bei uns seit,
stellte bei uns wegen seit gestern,
die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 8 von 10 auf einer Schmerzkala.
Als begleitete Zyptome die Patienten über Bewegung,
die Einstrahlung, die Hypo-Paristisien,
die Hypo-Paristisien und die Parastisien
an den rechten Unterschenkel bis zum Großzehe.
Parastisien, nur Parastisien, Krippen.
Genau, nicht nur Parastisien, nicht die Pferde.
Krippen.
Aber sie haben auch Taupausgefühl oder?
Taupausgefühl, das heißt Sensibilitätstören, Parastisien.
Hypo-Stesi.
Hypo-Stesi, ne?
Nein, nein, nicht Parastisien.
Parastisien oder Hypo-Stesi?
Ein bisschen anders, dann sprechen wir.
Okay, machen wir nachher.
Und der Patient berichtet das, die Patienten berichtet das,
dass die Schmerzen nach Kartenaarbeiten aufgetreten seien.
Und die Vegetative an der Nässe ergab.
Sagen Sie nochmal, es ist ja so bekannt.
Sagen Sie doch mal, bei welcher Gartenarbeit hat es angefangen?
Ja.
Was hat sie gemacht?
Ja, sie haben eine schwierige Dinge angeheben.
Sie hat ein schweres Gerät hochgehoben.
Ja, genau.
Und als plötzlich, tritt, treten die Schmerzen auf.
Also dabei sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten.
Okay, gut.
Und die Vegetative an der Nässe ergab Schmerzbeerdingte in Zonia.
Und nach einander, nach einander, nach einemander,
durch das Leben mit der Meteorismus.
Und dass sie für die Erkrankungen relevant sind,
Die Diabetes Melutus seit Kindheit behandelt mit Ünselin Pump und arterielle Hypertonie seit 7 Jahren behandelt mit Mycartis Blas morgens Abends.
Hypercholestronomie mit Atorwastatin 7 mg abends behandelt.
Und Herr Schwerigkeit seit 1,5 Jahre behandelt mit Tabonin 120 mg.
Hast du die Hörschwierigkeiten? Könntest du das mal konkretisieren?
Hörschwierigkeiten.
Du hast 2-fach Begriffe gesagt.
Ja.
Bis eine ist ein akuter Notfall, sie hatte ein Börschsturz.
Und jetzt hat sie ein Tinnitus.
Tinnitus, ja.
Also die Begriffe sollten sicherlich kommen.
Ja.
Und sie sei bisher keine Operation worden?
Du bist nicht operiert worden oder sie hatte bisher keine Operation?
Ja.
Und bezüglich Allergie berichtet die Patientin über Amoxicin Allergie mit Erritem.
Und frühe Allergie mit Rhinokonjunktivitis.
Sie trinken Glaswein am Abend.
Und sie rauchen 2-3 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Zigaretten pro Tag?
Zigaretten pro Tag seit 15 Jahren.
Nein, seit 15 Jahren.
Das ist ein Unterschied.
Seit 15 Jahren.
Ja, beide Drogenkonsum haben sie Glas oder Mariana probiert.
Oder Cannabis.
Aber in der Vergangenheit, ja.
Ja.
Liegt lange zurück.
Ja?
Ja.
Und sie sei bei der Engenie verheiratet,
haben sie zusammen mit zusammen.
Zusammen mit zusammen?
Ja.
In der familiellen Analyse finden sich Makul-Degeneration bei ihrer Mutter.
Und ihr Vater hat Tippknie.
Tippknie, was ihr macht.
Tipp gelangt.
Ihr Vater hat sich Tipphüftgelangt unterzogen.
Links unterzogen.
Und so aufgrund der September, der Patienten gehe ich von Verdacht auf Landen,
wir besoil, diskus, prolapsus aus,
differenziell diagnostisch, differenziell diagnostisch kommen,
die Örolitiasis,
... Knogen oder Knogenmetastase ...
... äh ...
... und ... äh ...
... dann ...
... äh ...
Ja, also wenn es kein Disko vorlässt ...
... was das könnte, ist noch sein.
Also Worst Case, sagen wir, die ist krass osteoporotisch,
ohne es zu wissen.
Äh ...
... äh ...
... Landen wird bezäule ...
... vorfallen oder?
Fraktur, ne? Also ...
... letztens ...
... also ...
... Wirbelkörperfraktur, ne?
Ja.
Oder was eben gerade noch gekommen ist ...
... äh ...
... eben nicht wie nach einer Karnalschiennose.
Hm?
Okay.
Ja, auch.
Gut.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Ja ...
... äh ...
... so erst, äh ...
... werde ich ...
... äh ... eine körperliche Untersuchung ...
... äh ...
... districtführen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ja, bei der ...
... körperlich ...
... körperliche Untersuchung ...
... äh ...
... werde ich äh ...
... lassex, äh und ...
... äh ...
... und äh ...
... andere ...
Test beführen und ich werde Muskelkraft kontrollieren.
Und was werden Sie noch kontrollieren?
Würde.
Was werden Sie noch kontrollieren außer der Muskelkraft?
Ja, so. Und ich werde mit ...
Sie hat von einer Hypersdisi oder Tribbelparasdisi gesprochen.
Was müssen Sie machen?
Ja, ich werde Sensibilität ...
Sensibilität, neurologische Untersuchung.
Neurologische Untersuchung.
Okay.
Jawohl.
Gut, was machen Sie noch?
Natürlich, ich werde Blutuntersuchung durchführen.
Laboruntersuchung, kleine Blutbild, dann CRP, BCG.
Mit welcher Fragestellung? CRP und BCG?
Ja, BCG. Es kann auch eine Multiple mielom sein.
Okay, gut.
Aber was untersuchen Sie noch im Labor?
Wenn Sie an die Vorerkrankungen denken?
Ja, Hemoglobin, A1, Glucose, Nierenwerte.
Die Zuckerwerte auf alle Fälle, ne?
Ja, und dann bei der körpelligen Untersuchung.
Natürlich werde ich über Maschke 1,5 Meter kontrollieren.
Und dann werde ich MRT veranlassen.
Ja.
Und so gegenabends, wenn ich die Computer-Set-Promografie veranlassen.
Gut, und wenn sich das jetzt bestätigt, dass sie tatsächlich einen Diskuspolars hat,
was würden Sie sagen, wären die Therapieoptionen?
Ja, Schmerz, Schmerzmittel oder Schmerzadaptierte Therapie
mit non-Romatismal,
non-steroidromatismal.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe ein paar ...
Non-steroidromatismal ist Türkei. Nichts steroidare, antiromatika in Deutschland.
Nichts steroidare, antiromatika.
Und dann geht man aber fast mit Opioid.
Und dann Physiotherapie oder kranken Gymnastik.
Genau, ja.
Und wenn alle konservativen Methoden nicht helfen,
was kann man dann noch einplanen?
Ja, ich werde eine orthopieche ...
Konsiver, das ist laut.
... oder gegenebenfalls auf Eingriffe oder Operation.
Ja, aber der Hinweis kam gerade,
die Injektion von Glucocorticosin als Therapieoption noch.
Ja.
Gut, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden über die Untersuchung der Frau Hase.
Und ich gucke mir die nachher auch noch an,
wenn Sie mit Ihren Untersuchungen auf die Narben haben.
Ja, okay.
Okay, wir haben ein bisschen ...
... zwischen drin schon Korrekturen gemacht.
Und da habe ich Ihnen oft mal so grammatikalische Fehler,
hast du noch ein bisschen aufgezeigt.
Ja, die ...
... was habe ich hier?
Genau, ich fange mal oben an.
Vorstellung der Patientin, okay, gut.
Also, was ich schon wichtig finde,
dass man den beschriebenen Hergang, wie die Schmerzen entstanden sind,
dass der präzise wiedergegeben wird.
Ja, also die Patientin hat sich wegen starker einschießender Rückenschmerzen
im rechten Lendenwirbelbereich vorgestellt
und berichtet über Ausstrahlung in den rechten Oberschenkel
und über Kribbelparastäsien an der Außenseite des ganzen rechten Beines.
So, die Schmerzen sind entstanden im Rahmen von Gartenarbeiten
beim Anheben eines schweren Gerätes.
So, das ist wirklich wichtig.
Und das muss am Anfang kommen, und nicht auch nachfragen.
Also, weil das eigentlich erklärt den Mechanismus,
was ist da passiert?
Gut.
Dann ...
Ja, das war dann alles okay.
Eine Sache.
Ja, bei den Allergien haben sie nachher,
dass reduziert oder haben das für allgemeine Frühblühe,
sie hat es aber sehr präzise gesagt, Haselnusspollen.
Haselnüsse blühen früh im Jahr
und das sind diese länglichen Würstchen,
die so an den Haselnussträuchern hängen
und die eben zu einer ganz frühen Zeit im Jahr
schon eine hohe Pollenlast mit sich bringen
und jeder, der ein Auto oder Gartenmöbel draußen stehen hat,
kennt, dass man ständig sauber machen,
weil die so viel Staub machen.
Und das ist natürlich für die Allergiker doof.
Genau.
Ja, wo ich auch nicht so einverstanden bin,
der Vater ist noch nicht operiert,
sondern sie hat gesagt, die Hüfttap ist geplant.
Der hat also eine Kokosatrose.
Ja, Kokosatrose.
Also er hat Hüftprobleme, hat sie gesagt.
Ja, die Tap ist geplant.
Das ist was anderes, als hat sich runterzogen.
Das ist also inhaltlich einfach nicht richtig.
Und ja, ich habe mir heute vorgenommen, mir das zu merken,
was mir auffällt.
Ich habe vorgestern gedacht, mit dem E stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Sie machen aus dem E immer ein Eh.
Gestern bestellen Schmerzen.
Sie sagen nicht, seit gestern bestehen Schmerzen,
sondern sie sagen, seit gestern bestellen.
Also sie machen aus dem E immer ein Eh.
Und das klingt fremdartig.
Und ich musste das wirklich nochmal nachhorchen,
um zu merken, warum verstehe ich sie so schlecht.
Ja, und dadurch ziehen sie die Wörter auch relativ in die Länge.
Ja, das heißt, das führt zu so einer breiten Sprache.
Und was wiederum erleichtert, sie verschlucken die Sylven nicht.
Ja, sie verschlucken die Sylven nicht, sondern die kommen alle.
Aber es ist eben so ein bisschen untypisch in der Sprache.
Und ich konnte das, ich konnte das wirklich nicht präzisieren,
beim letzten Mal.
Und deswegen habe ich extra darauf aufgepasst.
Ja, zum Beispiel Lebensmittel.
Nicht Lebensmittel, sondern Lebensmittel, haben sie gesagt.
Also ja, das klingt völlig anders.
Und es macht es schwerer verständlich.
Gut, das werden sie aber jetzt so schnell nicht ändern können,
denke ich mal.
Das haben sie sich jetzt so angewöhnt.
Ich kann es ihnen nur als Tipp geben,
das ist praktisch das, was diese Hörgewohnheiten so ein bisschen beansprucht.
Ja, gut, alle anderen Sachen haben wir eigentlich direkt geklärt.
Wenn es kam, da haben wir nochmal der schöne Fehler,
den sie am Anfang nicht gemacht haben, haben sie aber hinterher nochmal gebracht.
Dann, ich werde ein MLT veranlassen.
Dann werde ich ein MLT veranlassen.
Es ist immer dasselbe.
Ja, gut.
Dafür reißt Ihnen keiner den Kopf ab, ich sag es Ihnen nur.
Es ist einfach so, es gehört andersrum.
Ja, gut.
So, ich habe ein bisschen gemault.
Aber ich will sie auch nicht im Unklaren lassen, wie die Situation ist.
Gucken Sie nochmal, dass sie in einen guten Sprachfluss kommen,
dass sie sich die Formulierung ein bisschen vordenken
und dass sie sie einfach für sich alleine mal laut vorlesen.
Gucken Sie sich möglicherweise einen deutschen Zuhörer
und sei das irgendeiner der Referenten aus Berlin,
erzählen Sie denen nochmal die ganze Geschichte.
Sie müssen es sowieso noch einmal in schriftliche Formen bringen für sich selber.
Und wenn Sie es dann ablesen, haben Sie eigentlich auch nochmal
eine Chance, die Aussprache und den flüssigen Vortrag zu üben.
Und dann kann ich Ihnen nur wünschen, dass Sie ein Discos-Prolaps kriegen
in der Prüfung.
Also nicht Sie, sondern als Patient natürlich.
Oder irgendwas, was Ihnen so ganz leicht von der Hand geht.
Also, wann müssen wir daumen halten?
Nächste Woche?
Ja, am 20. Juni.
Am 20. Juni.
Okay, das ist der Geburtstag von meinem Sohn, das muss klappen.
Meine Tochter gibt es doch.
Ja, gut.
Dr. Gündiz, Sie klären noch einmal die Begriffe.